good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday it
is hump day hope everyone's having
an amazing wednesday so far do not
forget i know it's easy to forget
do not forget to hump someone you love
it is so imperative thank you for that
reminder i mean dew is here so we're
celebrating in style and speaking of
style i'm switching it up today
you look lovely thank you so much well
it is so hot in new york like
there's a heat wave it's just and it's
rains like every afternoon because it
gets so hot
it's and you saw it last night's rain
was going to break the heat wave but
today it is still so hot it's going to
get up to 90 today so i was just like
you got a dress for the weather and so
i've just been really
going into the back of my closet and
trying to wear all of my clothes can i
ask you something that like maybe you'll
agree with me on sure when you like show
up somewhere like wearing something
unusual like not unusual but different
than like what your normal garb is and
everyone's like
don't you find that so rude like no 100
i was like nervous to walk in here today
but i feel
totally supported by everyone in the
studio yeah for this new look i actually
thought when you came in because i did
wear a dress yesterday and you when i
walked in you were like
a dress and i didn't yeah you did you're
like simla
no i didn't yes you did no it seemed it
was just dress in hebrew
i didn't say that you both did yes you
both did thank you
my memory and i was like you know what
i'm gonna support jackie because like
you know you sometimes it's like i
always think of when erica jane rolled
up in berlin in that latex outfit and
teddy mellencamp was like giving her
[ __ ] for it do you know what's so crazy
is i walked in here this morning and you
said to me seamlah
yeah i said you look so sweet right but
like so yesterday i said to you simla
and you didn't feel supported
you were like and then you're saying
no i'm not i'm not trying to clown like
i'm not trying to like bring you down
i'm just trying to say like
i recognize like it's just a thing
people do and they're like when you
dress different everyone like makes it
think of it it's like just leave me
alone like yeah no stop let me wear my
seamless go away
no this dress is really like not meant
for new york city vibes
but just like this heat it's what are
you supposed to [ __ ] wear no we both
look like we're going to the country
club we're just doing different
activities yeah
i'm headed to the tennis court i'm
headed to lunch with the ladies which in
reality like
if we ever were at a country club like i
would be at lunch with the ladies you
would be at the tennis court yeah for
sure hopefully they have pickleball
yeah um wait so we have such a good show
today it's wednesday it's hump day which
usually means a few things
one it means we're humping theo still
happening do not worry
second is we usually do dear toasters we
have decided to postpone today's deer
toasters till tomorrow
because we just did a deer toasters
yesterday with chelsea handler which was
so iconic and we're so glad everyone
enjoyed that episode
and today's episode is already going to
be extra long because we recorded a
fabulous interview yesterday with
someone who we admire so much
so much who we talk about all the time
all the time kevin o'leary mr wonderful
from shark tank was here he was so funny
i have to say i think i was like most
surprised by him out of all the guests
we've ever had he was so thoughtful we
had like a really
interesting conversation he talked so
much about his wine company which went
public yesterday
yeah so he was just giving us like
business tips and we did our first ever
wine tasting on the show which was so
interesting i feel like we learned so
much and usually i mean i don't want to
spoil what we drank and how it tasted
but i was really pleasantly surprised
because those were not
categories that i really venture into
and so he was in studio with us we have
the video up on our youtube channel it's
also going to be at the end of the
podcast
i really implore you to watch a youtube
video he was being so funny he wore this
crazy [ __ ] outfit
and he's just very charismatic and it
was honestly one of my favorite
interviews we've ever taught it really
was like we came in with our questions
which we got to ask like all of them but
then also the conversation just
took he flipped the switch on us no like
it just
went you know it's just a conversation
it was like 40 minutes yeah so it was
really interesting to talk to him i
think we had such a great conversation
probably one of my favorite
toast interviews that we've done and we
just love having a shark up in the joint
we're now three
weeks three sharks barbara kevin kevin
who's your next
dream shark uh i mean like if i went on
the tank i would really want lori to
invest in my deal or mark but who would
you want to come on the toast laurie
laurie that would be a good one yeah
lori also i think out of all the sharks
like has her
social media game down pat she like
kills it on tick tock and stuff so
i like would just love that synergy yeah
i'd like to get robert
you know how i feel about robert i know
you're obsessed with him
no no i mean and now it's changed and i
really feel like the more i watch shark
tank
like the more that i did watch shark
tank you really come to appreciate mr
wonderful and
even as he explained in the interview
yesterday it's like he's being kind and
telling people to
to go back to their date jobs he was
making so funny so like i
really can appreciate that but i like
that robert always makes the
entrepreneur like feel special
yeah even some people aren't special and
they shouldn't think that they are
not like all people are special their
companies aren't all special
[Laughter]
it's like that's like in um younger
where she's like why are you special
she's like i know that i'm not
yeah right and that's the right answer
have you been keeping up with younger
the season finale i think it's on
tonight serious finale
there's one more episode i'll get there
monday yeah it's not anything
pressing um but that's our programming
update our second dear toasters of the
week we're going to move to tomorrow so
we can spread that out a little bit and
you can just enjoy mr wonderful today so
we have that we have the fast five we
have your housewives of new york recap
and we're just like alive yeah we are
we've got a lot to do
and i guess we should just get right to
it you think
i don't know i thought that's where you
were going no i just uh you just like
threw back at me i didn't really have
anything to share
i didn't do anything fun yesterday
anything fabulous
no i just like yesterday was the busiest
day of my life like work work work
meetings meetings meetings and
unfortunately those types of days while
they're good for productivity they're
not great for this segment of the
podcast
oh i understand no but it's good it's
good to see everyone getting back to
work
yeah i did um i did read some of our
podcast reviews yesterday i don't know
what i don't know i that's one of those
things like i just don't go towards for
my own mental health
but something was just bringing me to it
and they honestly weren't terrible yeah
no sometimes they're not terrible and
even sometimes when they're terrible
like maybe you could learn a thing or
two like i've seen a few things where
it's like no yeah you're onto something
like yeah usually
like if you usually the reviews are
either five star or one star like one
star
you're like a former disgruntled toaster
like you know yeah leaving a review just
because you feel like it and five stars
you're just like a normal person or four
threes where it's like okay
it's actually valuable i hear you i i
couldn't see that
i would say that our biggest like um
valid critique
is that like we talk about so much stuff
like so many stories different
industries
and not always do we have a hundred
percent of the facts and i'm here to say
like that is valid
but we are also like not encyclopedias
like there's only so much information
we can retain every day for a million
different stories like
so yes i i do i feel that
especially yesterday when i was talking
about that ellen interview that i had in
a dream it was a real interview okay
i think that that's fine that you were
confused yes so like
that's a valid um critique for like what
do we do about
no i i see that and i hear that and i i
get it but then it's like okay
if i'm not fully in the know on a story
like so we just shouldn't talk about it
but then it's like we're not talking
about stories that are happening so
i think that most people when they read
stories like they got the gist of it
they don't know every single detail
so i think i think it just it depends
you know and then the other critique
which is out of our control but
completely valid is the fast talking
vocal fry um because literally i watched
our episode from yesterday and it was
fine and up until we started talking
about siesta key
jackie it was we did not take a breath
like it was so [ __ ] fast and i'm like
i see what people see okay i'll
i could try to keep that in mind i think
i was probably talking quickly about
siesta keem you were excited
because then we needed to get to the
bachelor usually i talk fast when i feel
like
no one wants to hear what i'm saying but
we always want to hear what you're
saying all the time well speaking of
siesta key i'm caught up after last
night i caught up there on the island i
need to talk about this island like it's
so sickening
they the premise is that sam j lo like
book the island for everyone but like
kelsey's invited and has her own house
like sam jayla is not paying for that
mtv
is mtv is they're there for a month it's
actually it's exactly what i was saying
needed to happen like we need them to be
in a confined space cameras everywhere
we won't miss a thing so
that's an innovative way to film during
coven 100
i'm so excited and i look forward to the
next episode i'm so glad that i'm caught
up on the key because
these kids are crazy you're keeping up
with the key i'm keeping up with the key
for sure oh and
in bathing suit the battle of the
bathing suit which is the funniest
storyline i think i've ever experienced
in my life
so obviously these things were filmed
six months ago so i was like let me see
where the
brands are at where the brands are at
now i checked out juliet's i checked out
kelsey's
saw how many followers each of them had
jmp has like better branding social jmp
has 80k
by kelsey owens has 60k still good and
then i checked out the swimwear because
i wanted to see what everyone was making
and i did not expect that anything would
be for me because
kelsey and juliet have extremely
different bodies than i do
but when i was checking out jmp the
label i found what i think is a bathing
suit that will really suit me
she like sells her tops and bottom
separately so there was a bottom that's
like my high waist cut which i like
and then there was a top that looked
like it could hold a big breast
and so i was influenced and i purchased
i purchased
wow i'm really excited to share my
updates you must keep us abreast on the
battle of the bikinis
i will keep you abreast on whether or
not my breasts
are kept or kept depressed are kept
impressed by jmp the label
but i was really like there were some
really cute styles that i felt like
i could squeeze myself into that's great
yeah all right
please keep us appreciated i will keep
you abreast um
okay well now i feel comfortable i feel
comfortable sliding into there's so much
to discuss chris harrison
about two premature there's so much to
discuss claudia you're gonna be
explaining some things to us today
there is so much youtube drama like and
i actually know about it this time
oh okay well even your conjecture we we
enjoy yeah but sometimes when there's
youtube drama like it becomes like
trending
i like learn about it once it becomes
trending but i've actually been
following
this podcast pretty frequently for the
last like year ever since i
like became obsessed with tik tok
because it's like a tick tock thing okay
great so without further ado
to do where are you right here because
it's humpty hump someone you love it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
quinn's do you like the quality of
designer clothes but don't like the
prices then you'll love quince
how many times has a price tag stopped
you from buying something you really
wanted
why does true quality cost so much well
now it's affordable at quince
with quince you can imagine waking up
one morning and everything you've wanted
is half price
at quince that's not a dream that's
reality luxury products don't have to be
expensive but they're marked up
8 to 10 times by retailers quints will
connect you directly to the factories
that make
products for the world's leading luxury
brands so you get the highest quality
products at an insanely low
price it's true like you will die when
we went on the website
cashmere bags home stuff for the home
beddings it was
betting it was actually crazy how
reasonably priced it was compared to
those luxury markups
and it's just fun to shop for things for
your home for yourself treat yourself
at quince you'll find the finest apparel
cashmere bags bedding accessories and
more
at 50 to 80 less than what you pay for
the same quality at the most expensive
luxury brand
products they have washable silk
loungewear in pajamas italian leather
bags
100 grade a mongolian cashmere sweaters
and sets
belgian linen sheets their goods are
incredibly high quality they're made in
a sustainable way and they are sold at
radically lower prices
it is 100 factory direct so there's no
retail markups or
middlemen you can compare quince
products with any premium branded ones
and you'll see why their customers rate
quints so highly
to get 50 to 80 off top of the line
clothing and home goods
plus free shipping text tmt
to 64000 that's tmt as in the morning
shows tmt
to 64 thousand terms apply available at
onequince.com
terms text tmt to 64 000. love it
okay first story the big story of the
day well there's two today but
a month the bigger one the bigger one
chris harrison is leaving the bachelor
franchise
for good after dramatic exit
negotiations
it's official chris harrison will never
return to the bachelor franchise
harrison's departure comes following a
media spectacle
of a controversy that erupted when the
longtime host made racially insensitive
comments
defending a contestant from the
franchise numerous insiders tell variety
that harrison wanted to stay with the
hit franchise which he has hosted since
it premiered
in 2002. harrison is said to be very
passionate about bachelor nation and was
hoping to make it work to keep his job
but as the situation escalated his term
became his team became outraged
with the dragging out process and was
unhappy with the network and studio not
publicly supporting harrison
since he has been with the show since
the very beginning and is an integral
part of its success
within the past few days harrison's
lawyer began to quickly explore an exit
package
which we found out he got an
eight-figure mid-range eight-figure okay
but then i also saw he
wanted 25 million he did not get that so
it's somewhere between 10 million and
25. the initial variety like press
release said mid-range
eight figures which the middle of eight
figures is 50 million dollars so
everyone was like shook
then i read and paid chicks he wanted 25
he didn't quite get that
so i'm thinking something like 15 to 20.
i'm thinking that too
which is nuts like pay me 20 million
dollars not to work on a sinking ship
okay like oh my god did chris harrison
make out like a bandit or what like
and oh by the way i screenshotted this i
forgot i don't know if i sent it to you
the ratings are in for
um oh no you didn't send it for katie
thurston season ready okay
i'm so curious let me give you some
backstory please do rachel lindsay's
season 5.7
million yes okay becca kufrin 5.6
hannah brown 6.1 that was a high point
for the franchise claire crawley
4.8 tasha 5.1
katie thurston 3.6
so that's not good that doesn't sound 2
million less
it sounds like the chart went there was
a dip and i think there are a lot of
people in batch donation for some reason
who like
will fight a war for chris harrison like
some of the things i'm seeing online
people are just like
obsessed with him and when these numbers
came in it hadn't been announced yet
that chris harrison wasn't returning and
i actually think next week's numbers
will be even lower like
people standing in solidarity with chris
howell not even that night one
numbers are always higher like you yeah
yeah one because people want to see what
the season's about night one is always
like they pull out all the stops
let's talk let's let's look at the
ratings mid-season when they start like
really [ __ ] pulling teeth
and even the fans of the show might skip
those episodes and
i thought it was really interesting
during like the very beginning of the
episode i checked to see how many
followers katie thurston had
she had 612. last night i checked she
had 630.
it's like you seem bigger she's 612
before the episode premiere yes
that's not good yeah so i just think
it's indicative like this franchise
truly is a sinking ship yeah and so
for chris harrison i think like if
if i were him like i would be very
pleased with my situation i'm very
curious to see where we go from here
because
although the tasha and katelyn thing is
really fun i don't think it's a
permanent solution
i agree i think the show is on its way
out it seems like but
it also seems like he would have rode
with it till the end he was there since
the beginning oh yeah
and i'm sure according to this article
if he had his way
he would be back on the show yes and i
think that a lot of the um
the reason why he got so much money is
he's not allowed to
ever speak on this scandal or anything
that like went on beyond
like the producers behind the scenes
like ever again and i'm sure if he
wanted to if he didn't get enough money
he could have written a book
or done an interview or got paid for
something similar amount
to just blow it all up like yeah
i'm sure there's a like really [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that goes on behind the scenes like
if you think about the genesis of like
everything
chris harrison has witnessed not even
this like rachel and matt scandal like
korean since 2002 korean and paradise
like there's
and they like glazed over a lot of what
happened there like there's so many like
[ __ ] up things that go on behind
bachelor
bachelor behind the scenes even i'm sure
what went on behind the scenes here was
even more [ __ ] up with the whole
rachel and matt thing so he could have
really blown it up and i guess they just
wanted him to
shut up yeah so they paid him
yeah and like when this show gets
canceled
inevitably in the next like three or
four years i really feel like that's
true
um like chris harrison's gonna be
like laughing with his 20 million
dollars yeah and
never having to work yeah i wish someone
would pay me
mid-range eight-figures not to work i'm
sure he's going to try and work again
yeah i mean like this scandal has like
really made him so famous
and like i think everybody knew who
chris harrison was but now that we're
all talking about chris harrison's like
oh you know who he was too like you'll
talk about it with someone random it's
like how do you know who chris harrison
is
yeah and like i feel like there's so
many un
finished loose ends like things i have
questions about like it's so weird to me
that like chris harrison
is no longer on the franchise because of
this big scandal that happened with
rachel connell and like rachel corconell
is like moving in with matt it just
feels like
it just feels like i'm confused yeah i
agree
so um but it's nice to just know what's
going on in the franchise and i'm sure
they could have
kept being like you know the pause the
pause like right
he's not doing bachelor paradise i doubt
he would be doing michelle season and
then it would just be more and more
waiting so
now we know and i'm sure they'll start
looking to really fill the job
permanently because i don't think
these one-off characters are going to
work that was going to be my next
question do you think there will be like
a
like a new like maybe emmanuel ochoa
becomes the new i think that there
should be if they want stability
like i think that would get people
excited if it was someone that people
really like
yeah or maybe it's a host that that we
don't know that well so it's like
their association is only the bachelor
still just like how chris harrison
was in the background yes so i think
that they
can find someone great for the position
yeah make sure you know a million girls
would kill for that job
literally it'll be interesting to see
who does get the job
yeah and if you're asking me who should
get it i think it should be the snatcher
she's proven that she can talk about the
bachelor she's time and time
time and time again so that's my pick i
think that's a really good one
are you ready for our next story yes i
am trisha paytas quits frenemies podcast
a mid-feud with frenemy
youtube sensation trisha paytas is
stepping down from the popular weekly
podcast for enemies amid a disagreement
over their conduct on the show
please explain okay what's going on
trisha paytas
is a popular youtuber yes
they've like had a very interesting
career thus far very messy
very scandalous but trisha has like
really found
this very um like good project for her
she joined the frenemies podcast which
is a podcast produced
produced by h3 productions i need you to
just keep up because it's like a weird
family circle okay okay
okay h3 productions put together this
podcast called frenemies and hire tricia
as like the talent to host with this guy
ethan who owns
h3 productions okay so it's like tnn
yeah yeah yeah
ethan is married to a woman named gila
okay she's israeli i don't know that
doesn't matter i just it's a fun fact
so this podcast blew up and really did
great things for trisha's career because
she
they've kind of always had this um like
salacious
scandal like aura to
trisha's brand like it's always been
just kind of messy but this podcast blew
up
ethan blew up with it like ethan was a
popular youtuber
creator before but i think this podcast
took them both to like a great level
people were obsessed with this podcast
like i never watched it but i've always
seen like clips and i've always watched
it's hysterical like trisha's nuts they
dress up in these insane costumes and
talk about serious things
it's very funny h3 produces it
and on monday oh one more small fact
and then why people like love watching
this journey for trisha is because
trisha met a guy on h3 the podcast he
works for the podcast
and it's ela's sister brother
sorry so trisha and ethan the host of
the podcast
he's been dating someone they're
siblings yeah hila's married they have
kids with ethan
and trisha just got engaged okay okay so
it's kind of become this like beautiful
thing and they've like fought on the
podcast before and like everyone always
like freaks out because like the clips
go viral
trisha does struggle with bpd she's
they've been very
open about um their journey with
mental health um so that's just the
context that you need okay
so on monday they did an episode and at
the end of the episode they do like a
deer toasters like a
viewer advice and trisha says
that they don't want to do this segment
like they think it's stupid they think
it's like tacky it's what people do when
they don't have any more creative ideas
and it kind of started this like very
weird contentious conversation
okay about money and about the show and
how ethan's like that's so mean like we
all he
he hires h3 productions is his company
trisha gets hired as talent
he was like we work really hard like
putting all these segments together like
that's like mean to say that you don't
like our like advice segment
and then trish is like well don't say
you do everything
and then ethan's like no i mean we do do
everything but that's not what i said
and trish is getting visibly upset but
then she keeps saying like i'm not upset
i'm not upset i'm not upset
and so then ethan's like i feel like
you're gaslighting me like you're
clearly upset like let's just talk about
it you know
and then trish is like you're guest
lighting me telling me how i'm feeling
so it's like you're guessing i'm
gaslighting
okay the conversation that gets very
contentious and they really start
talking about money it's actually really
interesting to hear how they split up
the money
the show is very successful it's an h3
production they split
adsense revenue podcast revenue on it's
a podcast and a youtube show
so they split it like 50 50 but they do
take five percent from the overall thing
for
the production to pay um all these
employees who run the show
the employees being trisha's fiancee
moses right
moses so trisha is going on about how
it's like not fair how they don't
deserve the five percent like in front
of the crew
who's like literally working on the show
they're only asking for five percent
it's not a lot
so it gets very very contentious
episodes on monday
monday night the i guess they also do
like a vlog series i've never seen it
the crew says we don't want to do the
vlog like you were very rude to us
trisha like saying how we don't deserve
our five percent so they kind of like go
on strike
tuesday the episode drops to the public
they have like a patreon so
like people get to see it first on
monday it drops on tuesday is it on
patreon or
no it's like a membership i don't know
what the infrastructure is just always
like to know what tools people are what
other creators are
100 tuesday the episode drops
boom tricia drops on her own channel a
video i'm leaving frenemies
she said you know i'm i'm she said that
like she's not gonna apologize for how
i'm sorry
her pronouns are they them i'm really
sorry they said that they're not gonna
apologize for how um
they feel but their delivery was wrong
and so
i do believe the frenemies community has
sided with ethan
because also in this fight that was on
air it was very awkward to watch
trisha said gila and ethan just
announced that they are having a baby
and i think it might be twins like there
was this whole announcement and they
made the episode last week like a lot
about that
and trisha was was like you know you
made the episode title pregnancy
announcement
kind of like you know using me for clout
people thinking i'm pregnant and it was
just like
not about trisha at all it was about
like ethan and gila
and it just feels like this is what i
think happened
no verification i just think that they
hired tricia to be the star of the show
and
they are like trisha is insane like
she's
talent oozing out of her pores but the
community like
started to really love ethan and fall in
love with ethan and hila's love story
and of course everyone was like freaking
out when they got pregnant and i just
think trish was like i thought the show
was about
like supposed to be about me like he was
very much supposed to be the
captain of the ship and the serious one
to kind of prop up trish but the fans
like love both of them equally
and i just think there's been a lot of
attention on ethan and hila
because of the pregnancy and stuff and
they've fought before like with the
siblings and it's been really awkward
like the
the couple's fighting because moses and
hila
are sister and brother yeah but and they
then ethan and trish work together it's
actually like a really toxic
potentially yeah but even though they're
not working together anymore all four of
them like they're always going to be in
each other's lives
right or they should be so right before
this like people were like there were so
many tick tocks like glamorizing like
how you know trish is in the best place
of her life like she struggles a lot
with mental health she was dating jason
nash
yes and she was her and ethan were the
one who blew that whole
like dom david dobrik's hand like they
started that like they really did so
it was like a really influential podcast
and now
i just don't know where we go from here
a lot of people are saying that like
trisha like always fake quits like
she'll be back but
she made a v sorry they made a video and
it seems very real
and the frenemies people are like
so upset trisha was trending all day on
twitter yesterday yeah that
is upsetting because if you love a
podcast and then it ends like
people would be devastated at the toast
oh my god and especially like in the
in the in a day like you know these
weren't i mean i'm sure there were
forces that were at play for a while but
just to have one
bad episode in one disagreement and then
to make the decision in 24 hours and
then make it so publicly you can't come
really come back from that
it was very erratic if anyone could it
would be trisha
yes that's so her so a lot of people
aren't worried the story is so big now
i've seen it everywhere i don't know how
you put the toothpaste back
in the channel well so ethan is actually
very good about like dealing with trisha
because she
is you know her own their own celebrity
you know
and they've kind of like stormed off the
show before and ethan like handles
trisha
perfectly so they actually i could see
them like
literally sitting down for another
episode and pretending like nothing
happened like that's like they can do
that
i don't maybe in the past but i think
that this particular story has reached a
level that they couldn't just
pretend like it didn't happen but maybe
they could have a repro chamois
on camera this isn't even the worst
fight like literally they had a fight
like a month ago that went viral
um and trisha called ethan's wife
gila like a [ __ ] like it was it was a
family fight like that's the worst type
of fight to have publicly like airing
your dirty laundry
i think that fight was worse than this
one about money yes but
i didn't hear about that fight yeah well
because trisha didn't actually quit
after that fight she just like stormed
out and then
the next day she like apologized for
what she said sorry for what they said
interesting well as always i really hope
that they can work it out because
i hate to see a successful podcasting
duo go under i hate to see it
devastating
i think that everyone and they should
have like they should renegotiate their
terms
yeah and everyone should feel good about
what they're doing but i but i
like the setup that they have is pretty
fair i completely agree sounds as fair
as fair gets to me
trish has hired his talent like the
studio i believe is
in ethan's house but they bought a
studio in downtown l.a like you know it
seems fair to me they produce other
podcasts besides frenemies but trisha
doesn't think that it's fair so
let's go back to the table and find a
deal that works for everyone like i'm
sure ethan really and i saw his tweet he
really wanted to make this work
yeah that's what he deleted right i feel
like the deal is fair
yes i agree and it's like you signed up
she doesn't i think she might be being
unreasonable
they might be being unreasonable i agree
but if you want the show
you go that's what you get when you hire
talent you get
talent attitude yeah that's true
so if they want to make it work you got
to get back to the table
but trisha might be coming back we don't
know too much might have happened also
you say trisha might be coming back but
that's only because like you're hoping
she
they come back no i think that like this
is just like trisha behavior
she's just kind of like um like this is
so treasure
you know like i actually feel like we
could see trisha come back 100 like i
really would not be surprised
they have fought worse like i'm talking
after everything that you've shared with
me about the success of the podcast and
it sounds
so great i really hope that they come
back
and all of them are able to make it work
me too of course like it was a beautiful
it was a beautiful thing for so long
like when the podcast was going well and
their
you know partners are siblings like it
was great
they were a family yeah what category is
the podcast in
i don't know why probably comedy i just
like to know you know where
i believe it's big like really big on
youtube and like
like um performs like decently as a
podcast but they get dressed up in like
beetlejuice
they look insane like they're in that
they're having this fight and ethan is
literally wearing like
goblin face paint and trisha is dressed
i don't know what her costume was
what their costume was supposed to be
but it was like a lady who lunch i don't
know
it was insane and that's like the
production value is very high and it's
so
funny but i don't know
interesting okay well we'll keep you
posted and claudia will
continue to explain it all yes
constantly thank you so much for that
you're welcome
are you ready for our next story yeah
yeah yeah ready i really feel kept
depressed is it the next story
um that's brought to you by ipvanish yes
it is tell em claw my god cause you know
i was feeling a little
like remiss you know maybe like slightly
devastated even heartbroken if i didn't
let everyone know that today's show is
sponsored by ipvanish
what is ipvanish a virtual private
network a vpn for short
a vpn is a super important tool that
helps you safely browse the internet
you can use a vpn on your computer
tablet phone even things like your fire
stick when you're streaming media
when you use a vpn all your data is
encrypted what you're reading what
you're searching what you're watching
whatever it is that you're doing
that's important because you're doing
what you're doing on the internet is
absolutely nobody else's business like
even if you're just watching the toast
or frenemies
ipvanish helps you remain anonymous and
secure on the internet for listeners of
our show ipvanish is offering an
incredible 65
off just 3.49 for the first month or
31.49 for the year
here's everything you get with ipvanish
anonymous ip addresses you can
circumvent any online censorship
you can get protection when using public
wi-fi and 24 7 support
email with them chat with them even call
them they're always there to help so go
to ipvanish.com
toast and claim your 65 savings they
have plans starting at just 3.49 or 31
and 49 cents for the whole year now is
the time to sign up because with our
discount and their current promotional
offerings you can get a vpn
for 65 off their usual offering ipvanish
is the best of the best rated 4.7 out of
5 on trustpilot with more than 6000
reviews
so again that's ipvanish.com toast to
get the deal and start protecting
yourself online
love it thank you for that our next
story tiana taylor is the first black
woman to be named maxim's sexiest woman
alive
tiana taylor is making history with her
latest magazine cover on monday the 30
year old entertainer
was crowned maxim's sexiest woman alive
topping the title's hot 100 list
for 2021. taylor covers the issue in a
hacked off hands tank top
and vintage army pants showing off her
six-pack abs i saw tiana taylor wearing
army pants and flip-flops so i bought
army pants and flip-flops i mean this is
such a well-deserved award like after
um that kanye west music video like she
was literally like everyone's body goals
and she's a great selection for maxim
hot 100 i did not know that they never
had a black woman win which is like
crazy
um but this is fabulous i get like a
little bit of ptsd when we talk about
maximum hot 100 do you know why
i do know why i do know why and i will
tell you
it's my fault since i am the cause of it
um so when we were doing the breath so
that was probably four years ago maxim
release our hot 100 and their number one
was
hayley baldwin at the time and this was
really before you know
she popped off in the way that she has
she was like a guest model
yeah she this was pre style me made like
pretty bieber preach on mendoza
she was just like another celebrity
spawn who it was naturally good looking
and and like naturally rich
yeah and so i said that i felt kind of
like meh about the cover
whatever you were into it you thought it
was a choice i've always loved
this was also before the met gala where
she wore that pink alexander weighing
dress that really changed everything for
me about her
and it did chase kind of like the
frontier of fashion yeah and like with a
little thong poking out like after
i did a 180 on not that i had so far to
come with her i just was like pretty mad
like a 90 not a 180. yeah yeah i just
turned a little bit
just like looked over your shoulder
anyways so i was
pretty men you know we used to post
about stories that we shared on the show
and we would post them to our instagram
and in a rookie mistake jackie posted it
i
posted that she was maximum top 100 and
i and the breath felt meh about it
and i tagged her which is like a weird
[ __ ] thing to do
yep and then she commented and she was
like well good thing
you don't pick the cup good thing it's
not up to you and i was like oh yes
i saw it and i i wanted to kill you i
was like are you [ __ ] kidding me like
we get one comment from haley bieber
like what that's the one and that's why
you know what that's why it's so good
that we rebranded because if she ever
comes across our page again she won't
realize that we're the ones who felt met
and i just want to say like
i have i feel completely different about
haley bieber than
than i used to feel she was she's really
set herself apart
she won't recognize us like i have a new
chin you have new eyebrows like we're
two different girls than we were on the
breath
i used to have a bob and now i have the
longest hair on earth by the way we are
truly irrecognizable
because we're running from that i'm
running from myself like as much as i
actually
loved doing the morning breath like we
had we had such funny times like we had
such good shows like
it was really like really fun to do like
i actually can't even like look at some
of the clips or the episodes because
like i was so
ugly not only ugly i gave no
[ __ ] about the way that i looked like i
rolled out of bed i didn't like run an
iron through my hair like i just did
natural hair
big thick [ __ ] eyeliner that was like
so uneven the same jeans
every day dirty jeans which i stand by
that decision this big mole on my face
like
i just like had no regard for how i
looked and presented myself
and as much as i like look back on that
and i'm like so ashamed i'm also jealous
of like the freedom i probably had like
i sit here
and i do my best to be hysterical but
also like look like the best that i
possibly can like i'm always touching my
hair and fixing my lipstick
it's exhausting and like that girl was
so free like she didn't give a flying
[ __ ] what she looked like
yeah but also in your defense now back
then we had touch-ups
we had hair and makeup touch-ups so you
could roll out of bed and someone was
going to like
make you look kempt yeah but they didn't
but they did like i feel like
i feel like they did you more or less
story you would have looked worse
so um yeah those were good times but i
agree and it's just like so
interesting to watch the clips like my
hairs
no worries my eyebrows are so different
we're so different and you would think
like i actually look so different and i
really don't do like a ton of plastic
surgery like i get like
literally once a year botox in my
forehead that does not change the way
you look
and a little bit of lip filler like i
did get also get my chin done the chin
changed everything you can change
everything
and the lips like thank god you know
what when i first got lip filler
i was like this is so unnecessary but i
just want to be like sheena
like you know i just want to be like a
cool instagram or like blogger
reality star and i really didn't think
that i needed but it was like like a fun
thing to do
and now when i go through my time hop
and i see those curly little lips like
when i smile like that top one used to
curl up
i'm like oh my god like i'm so grateful
that i did this actually you didn't need
lips like for instagram you needed them
to balance out your skills
yeah no and like i guess maybe that's
kind of what's toxic about plastic
surgery because it never bothered me
before like i never looked at my lips
someone was like they're too small
but now i'm like oh my god i can't
believe i used to leave this house with
those little tiny little thin little
[ __ ] curly ass lips
yeah that is probably what's toxic about
plastic surgery but aren't you better
glad you look better
yeah thinking maybe i'll get a little
more anyways moral of the story is haley
baldwin bieber like you have totally
proven me wrong you aren't
anything but meh and the moral of the
story is that like i just want to like
distance myself from you like i have
been like obsessed since the day i met
her
um and i just don't want like you're
like you know haley baldwin drama like
to who's on me
like yeah no but it's not my drama
anymore like it's the breaths oh are you
are you letting go of the drama no like
i left it at the breath
okay because i still have trauma how we
got here is we're talking about maximum
hot 100 like i still have trauma tied to
it so i think we need to like just kind
of
collectively let that drama go
collectively let it go it's so important
like if that's what you're holding on to
i can't imagine the other things that
you're holding on to in your life
like i'm literally like i only remember
all the worse things that have ever
happened to me like sometimes i forget
like
i bartended on what happens live because
there's no room in my brain for like the
fun things i've done or the things i've
accomplished
only like the weird things i've said at
parties and the times like i've gotten
in trouble on instagram you know like
that lives in my mind rent free
100 i wanted to go and find like who
were like last year's maximum hot 100
and everything um if are you interested
in that yeah i'm always interested in it
i always just feel like megan fox wins
like every year i can't
she's so maximum oh do you also about
tayana taylor i just want to say like
obsessed and she is married to iman
shumper yes
who used to play on the knicks like i
don't know what he plays for anymore but
um
i just like stand them as a couple i
have a ship in the port it's pretty big
totally okay so i don't know if they had
one for 2020 but 2019 was olivia culpo
okay 2018 was kate upton obsessed
2017 was hailey baldwin just skip over
that one 2016 with stella maxwell
remember when she was
everywhere what happened to her she was
sitting miley like and she was in that
song that played all the time
got a stella maxwell right beside me oh
that lyric i don't know that one you
guys know it you know if you heard it
yeah for sure candace swan pulled 20 oh
wait 2015 taylor swift
were you aware of this what is there
like a sexy pick of her she doesn't do
that
um for sure there is let me see i have
to go and get it
wow you truly learned something new
every day about your favorite icons
you really do 2014 candace swan poll
2013 miley cyrus
2012 bar rafaeli oh my god
i love bar rafaeli what happened to her
she in jail she had like tax issues
yeah but i think they like let her go i
don't know it was when she dated leo she
was like the hottest thing for like a
couple years
yeah and i mean in 2012 she was the
number one she was literally the hottest
number one hut can you find the taylor
swift photo i'm just like genuinely
curious yes and then 2011 was
rosie huntington whiteley did i say that
right i'm
typing and reading at the same time yeah
i think i actually know which one it is
oh oh yeah
i mean that's like so editorial like
maxim usually has like big titties and
stuff
yeah um but that's so not taylor swift
and i love that she made it her own like
obsessed
obsessed 2010 katy perry
2009 olivia wilde 2008 marissa miller
2007 lindsay lohan 2006 and 2005 eva
longoria
deserved agreed speaking of um lindsay
lohan
she's like gearing up for some sort of
comeback she's in like a netflix movie
and she did this like stunning
photo shoot for some magazine interview
i think obsessed like i'm here for the
lindsay lohan
return to glory agreed 2004 jessica
simpson this is such an interesting list
it's just a moment in time i'm going to
just get to this
2003 christine aguilera 2002 jennifer
garner 2001 jessica alba
2000 estella warren it definitely is
like a
symbolic of the culture like what was
going on in pop culture for those years
like the jessica alba jessica simpson
years
the jennifer garner like i remember that
i just want to say like kim kardashian's
never been on the cover
never been number one i feel like now
she like
her brand is so different but like for
so many years like she could have been
she that was literally her
yeah that is weird that is weird okay
well are you ready for our next story
yeah
now that we've exhausted the hot 100
yeah ariana grande congratulates her
brother frankie on
engagement yeah love you both so so much
she said
so i know you'll be so excited to talk
about this because you love frankie
grande
you're just what do you mean number one
fan no i'm not like
no i know yeah no i haven't given you
the opportunity to talk
smack about him in a while well honestly
i do find him annoying but it's pride
month so i'm not going to be like
you know like obnoxious to frankie grant
yes and this is some really happy news
27 year old pop star congratulated her
big brother frankie grande and his
fiancee
hail leon on their engagement which was
exclusively revealed by people on
tuesday
she said the most beautiful love you
both so so much but
they're like getting married at the same
time yes that's sweet that is sweet the
photos are really sweet
and we just love a little bit of love
news yeah we do and we love like ari
always being so supportive of her
brother even when he's like thirsty
and honestly like people clown on on
frankie grande like myself included but
i
if i was ariana grande's brother or
would you act any differently
worse worse so like we need to give
frankie grande like a little room
like a little grace like he is doing
what we would all do naturally like
you're gay and your sister is a gay icon
like
how does one person like kind of
congest ingest digest internalize
all of that like it's very chaotic and
ringy grotto is just doing the best he
can no i understand and it's also like
frankie grande if he wasn't ari's
brother like would be her biggest fan so
like he's her biggest fan like gets to
go to all these awards so it's like of
course he's gonna
act out the way that he does like he's
having the time he's just a fan you know
100 like he's the luckiest fan in the
world
and i just think like we all need to
operate in a world where like we're just
a little bit more understanding of
frankie grande's chaotic energy because
it's like he's literally doing the best
he can and
just think of the circumstances you know
yeah yeah and i'm sure he's like
also trying to play it cool imagine how
much more he has to give no he's
probably like when he goes to these
award shows with ari
there's probably so many things going
through his mind so honestly i'm making
an official decree like
i'm going to operate in a world that's a
little bit more
forgiving of frankie grande like i
really am i just feel so beautiful
i always see jokes about him like on
tick tock and stuff and i'm just gonna
like especially jokes about like him
doing soul cycle like
i am going to give him a little break
love that how what a beautiful story
are you ready for our fifth and final
story it's the final story
i'm surprised the podcast reviews don't
say stop [ __ ] singing that song
i don't think that they would because
it's stunning oh okay i mean
i think it gives us the energy the the
boost that we need to
to report the fifth and final story as
well you know because sometimes we lo
okay every time sorry not to harp on the
song that's obviously annoying people
every time i actually haven't seen one
complain about it me neither i actually
did
i actually even saw one comment asking
us to finish the like keep going and
finish the entire song
but every time we do that song and i add
my weird like
[Music]
i'm literally professor ed neebley from
school of rock hundred percent
cause like when he when he gets them all
up in the front of the class for the
first time and he's like just do
on the base and he's like on the drums
like that's literally me
a hundred percent i think that i need to
reevaluate like who my idols are because
professor ed schnebly is a hundred
percent up there no i totally the fake
one not the real one
of course the real one sucks no the real
one sex and you know who you look like
today
sarah silverman she's like always
dressed in that movie like uh
like very long dress like she's still
proper
well look at me hey look at me
another jack black reference
also not to go down a completely
different rabbit hole but i really feel
like not enough time and respect is
given to the acting career of jack black
like
he's just like that funny guy but like
shallow hell is like a transformative
[ __ ] movie
school of rock is so iconic like i just
think he needs the holiday
holiday also whenever we like riff i i
get um
i feel like in the holiday like doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
like no that's like where i feel like
i'm having the date like i'm in the
movie i'm like
so i just feel like this episode like
was really integral for us to like put
respect
on jack black's name and frankie
grande's name and i feel really good
about the work that we've done here
today
100 fifth and final story
a little book news the jonas brothers
are writing a memoir
called blood blood
um from it's from an old youtube video
right yes yes
thank you for reminding me and i think
that's why they called that
i think it's an oman book is an oral
history of that youtube video oh how
interesting wherein they also compared
the 2013 breakup of the jonas brothers
to a tsunami
so joe jonas shared a little expert from
bill
he shared an excerpt from blood on his
instagram
are you okay it's just so funny
that kid's gonna be on the cover
on instagram he shared where he recalled
the intense emotions felt
when he and his brothers nick and kevin
decided to take a break from their band
written from joe's viewpoint the cake by
the ocean crooner completely just his
book
no i think it's by the three of them but
i'm assuming they go in and out of their
own perspectives i'm sure they copied
the lady gang format jackie i was
literally about to say like i hope that
they read the lady game book because i
feel like it's
actually sometimes very chaotic to write
a book with multiple people like there's
so many different perspectives and
sometimes they try to make it the same
voice the lady game book was perfectly
done like how to write a book from three
different perspectives so i really feel
like they should work with kelty
uh jack and becca i totally agree he
said the tsunami inside of me built
until it broke
and crashed through everything in its
path but sometimes things need to break
down so they can be built up again on a
stronger foundation
he said that's like a little corny he
says as we grow through our lives i know
i'll always have my brothers as family
as
friends and and as blood
[Laughter]
blood um yeah i mean
i didn't need a jonas brothers book but
i'll gladly welcome it into my space
does anyone else feel like they're
trying to make as much money in the next
in the past three years as possible so
they can like um try amazon specials two
tours
a book a hundred percent they can like
stop working again
i don't know if that's the point but i
do feel like they're constantly doing
the most at all times like
and their music is really good so i'm
not mad at all about it about it
their tour was unbelievable like one of
the best shows i've been to i will
definitely be going to the next one
but i agree they're doing like a lot
yeah i'm just curious what the strategy
is i do feel like they're working really
hard so that they can take time off
maybe in a few years especially as they
all have like young families
um but that is the vibe that i'm getting
like let's like just make the most money
which i also understand because a lot of
people like things have an expiration
date
and yeah comeback was so strong yeah and
and it wasn't just like a reunion it was
like no we're going to do this again in
the fanfares just as it was in like
2007. so
i i can respect them
get collecting all those checks me too
but i definitely got the same vibe from
like all of their media
like it's just a lot okay cool cool yeah
and like a book honestly does not sound
like a natural
thing because yes they have a story to
tell the breakup but they literally did
it in a two-part documentary like
oh speaking of documentaries i watched
the pink documentary i did not finish it
it's so good did you know pink is jewish
wow she was like oh i feel so guilty
well i'm jewish that's all we have
and i'm like wait really i didn't know
that you're jewish like i just didn't
know that like
live for it um it's such a good
documentary i'm only like halfway
through i just do wish there was more
performances it's really it's not a
concert dvd like it's truly a
documentary with like
tiny pieces of performances in it
interesting because i listened to
the album from the documentary on
spotify so i thought it was a lot of
live performances because
maybe at the end there's more that's
what i listened to i actually like used
it as a soundtrack for a run it was
really inspirational because she's also
like talking and inspiring everyone
around her and she did
on tour i had i didn't see her on tour
she did it i don't know if it's a cover
did she write that song
shut your mouth and run me like a river
it's on the album it's not her song it's
a cover yeah she did it so well
yeah and it's just really interesting to
see um
first of all the dynamic between her and
her husband because of course it's
you know very non-traditional she's the
breadwinner
he really he's not like a stay-at-home
dad but he when they're on tour like
takes the brunt of like
the the work while she's you know tour
while she's rehearsing and going to the
stadium and she tries to keep her kids
involved as much as possible
um but like whatever you think of like
pink's life on the road like that's not
it like it's literally like
motherhood and then she like runs away
for two hours to do a concert and then
comes back to motherhood like it's
actually really crazy have a lot of
respect for
being a mom is like her number one
priority like is she's such a mom like
she's
honestly a great mom very introspective
she's like she just seems like a person
who's been through like a lot of therapy
and she's like
really into her emotions um but she
likes that kid willow
100 times better than i didn't even
i'm only halfway through but like
literally the other kids like might as
well have not existed
but will's older oh my god i'm joking
that's what i get
here's what you get for saying you know
she did explain how like
yeah you're choking on your words god is
smiting me and i fully accept that
she did explain how like for the first
five years of willow's life like it was
just her and will
you're not allowed to speak on the
children then no i'm just trying to
explain what you said no but that's
maybe that's the sign no but what she
said was
like for the first five years it was
just her and willow and then like this
new baby came in and a baby's like a
narcissist like a baby
just lives that's she said that not me
the baby lives in its own world doesn't
like
think to be jealous of their older
sister whereas like willow who was like
the center of the universe
for five years so that's why she put so
much energy into
like willow's well-being and self-worth
she's just really like
worried about her kids like having high
self-worth i understand that but i also
feel like for whatever she's doing and
the kids are running around like the
older one is going to get to do more and
be
around more until the other kid whose
name i literally don't even
know is it um sage
you know that does sound right whatever
okay cool cool um
it's really good you will like it like
if you have respect for pink like you
will just get more respect
oh my god you guys my content plate run
it over i think it's not pertinent
like right now no i know but like i need
to watch why women kill i need to watch
pink documentary i need to watch summer
house i need to watch bull type and i
need to watch younger
and that's only the things i can
remember right now yeah i would just say
start with why women kill in summer
house
that's my plan okay that's my plan um
and those were the past stories and you
needed to know them let's dive into our
tv recap
right before our interview with kevin
o'leary and our tv recap is brought to
you by manscaped
our go to men's sorry our go-to for
men's below the waist grooming products
manscaped has a new product
new product alert new product alert it's
time to stop drop and order this brand
new shaving kit that they just launched
introducing introducing the ultra smooth
package
a specialized groin shaving kit to help
your man
buff protect and smooth his most
sensitive areas
they have a new crop shaver a crop
exfoliator and crop gel the name of all
their products is so funny and they have
such great branding
and then when the product comes like you
will be shocked it is literally
some of the the best men's grooming
products ben is obsessed
with everything that i got for him and
it all came in this like sickening
leather
um like very manly like travel case yeah
um because i have so many pouches and
when we travel like i give pink ones to
ben just like put all the [ __ ] in but
now manscaped has literally the best one
um so manscaped is the originators of
the electric ball hair trimmer they now
have a razor and set for men to get your
get get you trimmed from front to back
so
they can stop using your razors they can
start using their own crop exfoliator is
infused with ingredients that can soothe
clear and keep the skin on and around
your groin feeling refreshed
the crop exfoliator can help reduce the
risk of ingrown hairs and delicate
places
sometimes men are just like so rough
with their like
body um and manscaped is taking care of
men in your life so
yeah it's a great gift for a little
weird for father's day but why not well
if you're like you could give it to ben
for father's day
he's ethiopia theo's dad um they also
have a crop gel so you can see where
you're shaving with their unique
clear shaving gel just for the groin
it's pretty remarkable
with four essential oils it's like the
spa treatment with every every time you
shave and it smells
super nice ladies this is the perfect
gift to get for you and your man and men
your balls will thank you
it's time to get up close and personal
with the best tools for the job the
ultra smooth package from manscaped
and you can get 20 off and free shipping
with the code toast at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code toast at manscape.com
smooth it out fellas with manscaped she
will thank you i have to say
it's really like the best gift to get
for your husband for an anniversary or
your boyfriend it's probably the best
thing i've ever gotten for ben that he
uses
every single day no same she will thank
you and he will thank you and if
men are really hard to shop for like
especially when you need the good gifts
this is always
this is such a good gift like keep a tab
in your mind for when you need to get
all right the real houses in new york
was on last night the second to last
episode in the hamptons and it was like
chaos i can't believe we're still in the
hamptons it says if they're like
throwing it out no they're like on
jersey shore where they're just like in
a
house i mean i guess it's better than
like those shitty episodes we were
getting in the city when like no one was
in the same place
yeah so it's better um but it's so
chaotic like the group is just you know
when you start to hang out with
like people for too long like you get
that annoying feeling with them like
they're obviously having that feeling
i thought the the conversations in the
beginning of the episode between ebony
and luanne
i thought were pretty productive like i
do think luanne is well intentioned
but like she was being like like leah
was screaming everyone was screaming no
one was calling anyone angry
and then ebony and i think like ebony
really explained it in a way that luanne
could digest
because luanne has and actually ebony
said this perfectly
luanne is such a big ego like in fights
and stuff like she can't see anything
but
her wanting to be right so even though
there was something more important
happening with the conversation she's
like what will you apologize to me it's
like
girl like it's not about that like yeah
it also the conversation that they had
at that brunch
i i couldn't even follow it like what
were they saying i have no idea what
point
anyone like was trying to luann was
trying to make with education
and christianity and class like what she
was trying to say she kept telling
ebony i didn't say this i didn't say
that but what so what were you saying
and honestly like the conversation was
irrelevant and when ebony was trying to
explain like luanne
i do think luanne ingested it but also
she could not get over like well will
you apologize to me for what you said
about educate like
get over it yeah it's really not that
deep
it's not that deep and also it was it's
not subjective like
she has more of an a formal education
100
um and then the episode like kind of
calmed down for a little bit and then
like really picked up at the end and i
really feel like there was a lot of
interesting things going on
with the heather and leah of it all yeah
and i'm feeling very conflicted because
i actually really like heather she was
giving me like such cringy vibes the
whole episode like
and i think ebony also said it perfectly
like heather does mean well like i
really don't think heather like i think
heather was trying to help everyone was
trying to smooth out the situation was
trying to
be supportive to ebony but some of the
[ __ ] she was saying like was really like
um
cringe 101 and then when she came in and
was like
you are so articulate by the way like
that that was
that was that was like a low point that
was really awkward but i did i
so i don't know what where heather
leaves the show but i can understand
how and why she got it ever since she's
come to the house like really nobody
wants her there and she's really being
nothing but like trying to be positive
supportive nice and i feel like when
she's you know jumping into the
conversation and saying we just need to
listen to each other like she's really
trying to help and like no one else is
taking that pov because everybody is
like divided divided no but you're right
heather it's like genuinely like
a nice i think like a nice person who
means well and just wants everyone to
like be happy
that can be annoying a hundred percent
especially when you're in a bad place
like leah is
and why does leah just not like her to
begin with and then what leah said about
like heather having to be the moral
authority on everything having to
contribute to every conversation like
having to be right and know so much like
i could also see how that could be
annoying but does not justify that
reaction no leah gave a perfect analysis
of like why heather can be annoying like
she said she has to be in every
conversation and not only that she has
to be like the expert
on everything and it's annoying just
like talk you don't be the expert on
race you have to be an expert on the
election
it is a really annoying characteristic
and i think leah like read
her personality perfectly but leah's
reaction was so unwarranted and i
actually felt so bad for heather like
what a miserable [ __ ] trip like
and really all spearheaded by leah and
it's like what does leah have against
heather like
it's so bizarre and i think it's a
combination of
just lia and heather being like two
different people and like leah just not
liking her
and then also leah and heather are so
similar also leah like being in a bad
place
yes definitely and i again i understand
how it's annoying that heather
is the moral authority on everything but
she's a good
person well-intentioned like literally
hasn't said a rude thing to anyone like
constantly just trying to like
be a team player and so if anything
she's annoying
but like she's not mean no she's not
mean-spirited she's not that and the way
that leah treated her like that's how
you treat like an
evil villain like oh don't leave me in
the car with this and i loved when
heather finally thought like stood up
for herself and was like oh shut up
[ __ ] like
we're just sitting in the car and then
she threw the flowers and stormed out
she's so irrational sometimes
you know it's weird with leah because i
can't decide like if i think she's the
most irrational person because sometimes
she's just insane
and then sometimes she'll say something
that is just like so poignant
and i'm like you are so clear-headed
yeah which one is it i literally don't
know
get you a girl who can do both i think
it's both and i also think like
i don't know how she could have knocked
on on the trip but like to have to film
it's not fair to the other ladies she
should have left a while ago it's just
not fair like
to have this person who is so deeply
mourning to also have to be a housewife
but there's not enough women for her to
just leave yeah
it's weird it's weird but i loved her
outfit her carrie outfit
oh her carry outfit the the pants
yeah no again not for me but you know
sonia who said
she's dressed as leah and speaking of
sonia i think my favorite part of the
episode and why like i'm
like really liking ebony so far it's
like she's being so kind to sonia
and literally like made me realize like
no one has ever been like
outwardly like nice to sonia and when
she like called her friend to set her up
and she just keeps telling sonya that
she's worthy i like
i actually really believe like that
sonia needed to hear that i agree
and i think it's so nice and i'm like so
surprised by like how i never realized
how like all the women are like so mean
to sonia like
yeah she they're just always putting her
down and like i think she's always even
when someone is her
friend and confidant on the show like
she's always the sidekick like she's
never she's never the main character
it's like so true she's such a main
character
i mean when she was like supporting
ebony and like talking about race i was
like
this girl like she was just being so
everything of the sword yeah
and i think that like it's time it's
sonya's time it's sonya's
time i agree that was one of my favorite
aspects of the episode i love that ebony
like
sees and when sonia said like i feel
seen like i love that ebony sees her
that was a beautiful moment on the beach
like truly
also that activity of fishing and then
like a little beachside
lunch looked so fun they're doing a good
job with the planning on this particular
trip like the hamptons usually like they
don't do anything but i love this idea
of a pageant
yeah we'll see yeah we'll see i don't
think lydia goes i didn't see her in the
preview
yeah she shouldn't she's miserable she
shouldn't i i mean
we'll see we'll see um but i agree like
after this trip
heather i do don't believe films anymore
like why the [ __ ] would she
why the [ __ ] would she but and i'm and
i'm upset about it because i think that
they didn't give her a chance and i
think that she
is a nice person i think she has
potential and i think she's a nice
person too the podcast stuff is like
annoying but like who cares everyone
talks [ __ ] like that's not a real thing
who cares like i talk [ __ ] about
literally everyone i know even people i
like absolutely adore
right doesn't mean i don't like you i
just like um i just had something to say
i'm just a [ __ ] like
yeah normalize talking [ __ ] about people
like that you like it's like really not
a big deal
yeah yeah i'll talk [ __ ] about you
though oh thanks i don't talk to you
about you
liar um that's our show that is our show
and you know what we're gonna end it
because you need to go and listen to
this interview
with mr wonderful yes so a reminder that
if you're listening as a podcast it is
just coming up right after this
it's also available on youtube he was in
studio with us we did a wine tasting
it's a really great
video so if you can i would suggest
heading over to youtube but both options
are so premium
and can't go wrong we loved having him
it's such a fun interview you guys are
going to love it
so check that out and the deer toaster
segment that we usually do on wednesdays
is going to be tomorrow just so we can
even things out a little bit you know
100
we shall see you tomorrow have a great
day guys bye
you